un fuego abrasador la ola de calor que
azota europa ha causado incendios
forestales en portugal españa francia
croacia y turquía
hay llamas en este lado y ruta muy tengo
que cerrar la ventana hace mucho calor
mucho calor aquí
esto no se ve nada acaba de pasar un
automóvil a 120 kilómetros o más de 100
kilómetros se está acelerando porque
esto es peligroso explorar porque este
públicos los bomberos luchan por
controlar las llamas que son avivadas
por los fuertes vientos en españa el
fuego se extiende desde extremadura
hasta la provincia de salamanca
unas 3.500 hectáreas han sido consumidas
y cientos de personas tuvieron que ser
evacuadas de sus hogares la agencia
estatal de meteorología prevé que la ola
de calor alcanzará su punto álgido a lo
largo de este jueves con temperaturas
que probablemente superarán los 44
grados celsius
en francia a los incendios forestales en
el suroeste han arrasado desde el martes
tres mil 700 hectáreas de pinos
tenemos los incendios que son
importantes pero que tienen
características diferentes el primero
está situado en una zona de dunas con un
cierto número de campamentos y bastantes
puntos sensibles que defender
y en el otro lado tenemos otro incendio
que se extiende en pinos de más de 20
años no hay discontinuidad en la
cubierta vegetal y así se alimenta galo
para galopar
según los científicos las olas de calor
son cada vez más frecuentes debido al
cambio climático la semana pasada una
avalancha provocó un derrumbe en el
mayor glaciar de los alpes italianos por
las altas temperaturas